Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bar and a jacket jacket.
Okay.
On the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Um,
how's it going?
How's your week been going so far?
Has it been good?
I just got fucking screwed.
You know,
my wife wanted a rug,
right?
So she gets a rug sent over here just so we can look at the fucking thing right
there.
That's like,
that's like when they have you foster a dog,
you're just fostering it now.
You fucking own it.
The second is home.
So they're telling me,
you know,
he should haggle with this guy and haggle with them.
And I'm like,
all right.
They go,
yeah,
he's a,
he's Iranian.
They loved doing it.
They love haggling.
So I'm like,
all right,
fine.
I've watched enough,
fast and loud.
I know what I gotta do.
I got it all,
man.
I can't do that.
I mean,
you know,
no matter what the guy says,
I,
that's what I've learned from Richard Rawlings.
No matter what they say,
you can't do that.
Like,
Hey Richard,
uh,
I got this Ford Pinto and I got to pick a better car,
some car that he would want.
Right.
Whenever I got a 67 dodge coronet here,
I have $900 million invested in it.
I was wondering if you'd give me $40 for it.
And then he always says,
oh man,
man,
I,
I can't,
I can't do that.
I mean,
this car is even worth $15.
I'll give you,
I'll give you eight bucks for it.
I mean,
there's gotta be some meat on the bone for me,
right?
So I'm,
I'm doing all my Richard Rounds.
If I had the hair,
I'd be fucking rubbing my fingers through my hair.
Threw this guy's guy wouldn't budge.
He shows up,
we're at the house.
He knows she wants it.
I even,
I even fucking rolled the rug up,
like I was ready to give it back to them before we started negotiating at a,
he,
he just,
he wouldn't budge and he had this big silly smile and I started the light,
the guy and it,
it's the whole thing went off the rails.
He just kept going,
my friend,
look,
he goes,
you should be thanking me for giving you such a wonderful rug for this price.
I'm like,
what are you,
why are you always the hero and all of your stories?
What about me,
you know,
come my way a little bit.
I don't know.
He was so full of Shit.
Even his buddy,
he sat down and started laughing at one point,
but uh,
in the end,
oh,
Billy freckles.
Oh,
Billy.
Red Face.
Still fucking paid.
I still pay talk.
Did I pay top dollar?
I don't know.
She already negotiated down.
I came in,
that came in halfway through the fucking thing.
I thought I watched a couple of fast and loud,
so I was like,
I can do this shit.
And I didn't.
I didn't really,
I thought I was Richard Rawlings.
I didn't realize that he was Richard Rawlings and I was at jerk off stated in my
driveway.
Okay,
unreal.
I even did the cash to go do it.
I got cash.
Okay.
You can either walk out with a rug,
a walkout with this cash.
You just kept going through it.
I can't do that.
Ah,
you know what I should sell what?
I should've said that and I never did.
You know why?
Because I hate shopping in the fucking rugs there and it's a rug and it's on the
floor and it's done.
I don't even know why I negotiated with them.
I just wanted to get on with my day.
What?
What is it?
How much does this cost?
Hair beat it.
So I feel like an asshole.
If I could have just knocked him down $1,
I would have felt good.
God.
Jesus Christ.
This is why I have representation.
You know what I mean?
This is,
this is,
this is the reason why.
So anyways,
who cares?
Who gives a fuck that I just got screwed in a rug?
Well,
I do,
but I'm gonna pretend like I don't,
cause I got this big tour coming up,
uh,
the Billie Bible belt tour garment down through the deep south.
All right.
We're starting off in Savannah and then we're going up Knoxville,
Illinois of Chattanooga,
Memphis.
Then down Shreveport,
the knowns,
and then we're going to Hampton.
Then we're going to more building going is the most shit.
We ended up in Kentucky,
then Ebbets field,
then we go to the Kentucky Derby.
It's going to be great.
It's going to be a,
I'm gonna make sure I'd still work out.
Let me make sure I still work out,
you know what I mean?
And I,
I,
I'll booze at night.
I'm gonna try to not smoke a cigar,
the whole fucking thing.
All right.
I've had 12 cigars so far this year.
I figure if I can make it to June,
then I'm averaging two a month.
If I go the whole year,
rest of the fucking year,
then that was just once a month and then I'm all right.
You know,
trying to get him out of my life.
But every once in a while I got to tell you,
oh,
I got to tell you late at night,
late at nights when I always want one.
You know,
my wife will smoke the occasional cigarette,
which I'm trying to get her to stop doing,
but every once in a while she'd just down in the back porch,
she's enjoying the cigarette and I,
it just makes me want to come out there and smoke with Stokey,
listen to hear the sound of my voice.
Do you know it just got com.
I just want to sit out there.
I just want to smoke this cigarette.
Um,
that's what I want to do and I'm there to try to avoid doing that.
But I've been going to the gym every single day and I think it finally,
I finally snapped the other day.
I was like,
did not want to go and I'm fighting,
pulling into like a fucking Mcdonald's or whatever and I'm just making myself
drive to the gym and I didn't think I was going to make it and I just started
singing this dumb song,
you know,
it started off in my accent going,
I go to the gym every day.
It's just become a part of my life.
And if you don't want to be your fatty,
you go to the gym every day.
You can't write,
just starts singing this song.
He gets a little louder.
Oh,
I go to the gym every day you start banging.
It's just become a part of my life.
Slam on the steer wheel little.
And if you don't want a big a patty,
by the time I got to the gym,
I am screaming the song with my windows rolled up,
of course in some brutal hybrid English accent Australia.
I don't know what the fuck kind of accent it was.
Well,
I go to the gym every day,
you know,
Monday,
if you don't want to obey,
fade,
you go to the gym every day.
You can't,
ah,
once I get in there,
but the dude,
I fucking walk up the steps.
It's good walking music,
marching right up the steps,
the pop,
pop,
pop.
Once I stretch and I do the first set,
then I'm fine,
then I'm fine.
But I tell you something,
I don't know what
I've done.
I've,
I've passed a certain age where it's just,
it's just sucks every time.
It used to be like,
all right,
sucks the first two,
three days and then I'm good.
This,
this,
this has not,
this is not been fun from the first day I got in there and a,
I am officially an old fuck.
It's driving me nuts.
So,
but,
um,
whatever,
whatever
fucking gym,
there's always that little guy that's allowed at the gym.
You know that guy,
the short guy,
he's got a fucking yell at somebody sees like 20 stations.
Whoa.
You just want to be like,
dude,
we all see you.
Okay,
we see you okay with your little outfit.
This is a little guy at the gym,
right?
Or I work out and he's always yelling over at people and he's making jokes and
they're never funny and he doesn't have charisma.
And uh,
nobody's had the decency to tell him to shut up yet.
And it's this weird thing where I hate going to the fucking gym.
So every day I feel like eventually it's going to be me.
If you'd like to,
why are you,
what was yelling?
Why he was yelling over at people,
you know,
just fucking put on your little Walkman.
Okay.
Do your little curls.
Hey,
get the fuck outta here.
You know,
does it really have to do with him with the fact that I don't want to be there?
Um,
I'm an old school gym guy.
You only day I liked his bench pressing though.
What are your pension?
That's the only thing that I pay attention to.
I don't pay attention to anything else.
So I've been doing pretty good with the legs,
the legs and eggs over there.
Um,
anyway,
so you know,
last week on the podcast and I know I'm brutally on the rag this week.
I'm sorry,
I apologize.
Uh,
is I told you guys if you want me to do a,
if you want me to talk about some shit,
um,
you know,
on the podcast,
you want me to just tweet it to Hashtag uh,
uh,
t a m m p Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast.
And I gotta be honest with you,
actually,
people have sent me some really good stuff.
You know,
I was watching some of that playoff hockey,
got a couple of hockey questions.
I was watching it by myself crying into my beer,
you know,
follow everybody's giving shit to the Bruins.
I mean,
we were only like within,
we were like within 10 points of the fucking Canadians,
15 points.
It's not like,
wait,
was that fucking bad?
You know,
a couple,
two,
three,
seven games go the other way.
I mean,
we're,
we w we fucking won the division.
Um,
so anyways,
I watched it yesterday.
Um,
I watched some of the Montreal Ottawa game.
Regrettably,
I missed the second period,
but,
uh,
we're all the goals and all the action happened and I couldn't believe they
fucking kicked out PK.
Man,
that was bullshit.
I mean,
that was your classic two handers sit down for five minutes.
I'm just going to say what everybody else said,
but I actually agreed with that and I fucking hate the Canadians and I got it.
Oh No.
Yeah.
If we can pick the Canadian,
but you gotta think,
man,
that was the time,
you know,
they fucking home ice,
they had to do it.
They didn't get,
they didn't get it done.
They didn't get it done.
You know why?
Cause they're,
they're a quaint little city with a cute little river and they're happy.
That's the one thing I got when I was down in Ottawa.
There was satisfied.
They had this cute little town.
They were still considered the capital for some reason and you know,
it was a nice,
nice life down there.
You know,
you get up to Montreal,
everybody walking around with a carnation and they're fucking college.
It's really just trying to be somebody in their lapel,
I should say that color,
you know?
You know,
it's funny as I'm hell actually some Canadian fans actually really get pissed
off for me,
given these stupid little little fucking jabs.
And I'm like,
someone's going to go bill.
You think Canadians fans that dumb.
You didn't even know the kings were in the fucking playoffs.
That's trivial horseshit.
1516 x got gotta be an even number 16 fucking teams make the playoffs.
I was busy.
You're telling me the fact that I didn't know that the kings weren't in the
playoffs is worse than you guys booing the greatest goalie of the last 30 years
out of your building,
causing you to never win another Stanley Cup sense.
You realize you're on a fucking 22 year drought.
Oh my God.
I hope that fucking keeps going this year.
That would really,
really make my fucking year.
If the Canadians lose again,
it would just be fucking tremendous.
Be Tremendous.
Although I think they got a decent shot.
I was watching some of the West and another black hawks don't seem like the old
Blackhawks.
The kings aren't in it.
Who the fuck has left?
I think this is the biggest chance to win a cup and a long fucking time.
Well,
I guess we want it in 2011 but you know what I mean?
They just,
they just had juggernauts out there and even as shit crybaby teams like the
Vancouver Canucks even,
they were halfway decent.
Right.
Um,
and I'll still say they cry babies as long as long as,
I don't know,
as long as burrows is still there.
The Sidis sisters,
whatever the file,
you know all those guys who could beat the shit out of me.
Oh,
tough on his podcast,
Billy.
Um,
so anyways,
I watched a,
I actually watched the Black Hawks and predators.
Oh,
and by the way,
the Canucks fucking goalie,
that helmets,
the greatest thing I've seen in a hockey in a long time,
that's just phenomenal.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
Is that little,
a little fucking gun safe that he put a fucking visor on,
just carved out the middle of the thing.
I don't even know what it is.
It's the ugliest thing I've ever seen in my life and I love it.
He should wear that thing his entire career.
Never get the team colors and just understand that it's just a business.
You know what I mean?
I'm not trying to do any fucking Rah Rah sis.
Boom Bah horse shit.
I'm just here to stop pucks and they're going to hit me in the head and they're
going to mark up the beautiful paint job anyway.
So why don't I just paint it the color of the fucking puck and I'll stand here
and let you shoot shit at me until I get trade.
That's what I got out of it.
I'm sure there's probably some story about a war hero in there,
but I know I didn't look it up.
I didn't fuck it.
Look it up.
Um,
so anyway,
somebody asked me,
um,
Hawk a holic uh,
asked me a Haka holic 27 asked me how about Nashville only selling tickets to
Tennessee residents to keep hawk fans out of their building.
Um,
I don't know why they don't do that anyways.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You want to go to a hawks game?
Go to one in Chicago.
I don't understand why they got,
especially if you're in Nashville,
you know,
everybody there had some line dancing to go to.
So the place place would have been overrun by Hawk fans.
You know,
somebody day they end up,
they,
their half their fan base had to lose in a line dancing contest just so they
would be available that night to go to game one.
So they had to hold onto those tickets and wait to the till the sammies were
over.
Um,
I don't have a problem with that.
I would love to see that happen,
especially for Canadian fans because a Montreal Canadien fans,
they,
I always thought they traveled because they were great fans.
But I guess most of them can't afford to go to a home game.
Um,
I guess,
you know,
they don't have a lot of money up there and times are tough and you know,
when you blow it all on loafers in a blue sport coats or whatever the fuck it is
that they were,
they always dress like they go into parliament,
you know.
Um,
so I would love to see that happen.
It's f fuck you.
It's our building.
It's our building we can sell to who we want to.
I think it's great that they did it.
The,
the cheesy,
let's all wear the same color t shirt.
Um,
um,
I'm not a fan of that,
but uh,
what ads kind of weak,
but don't you think it was better though than all those Predator fans?
Got To watch that team blow a three goal lead?
That's one of the things I don't know who I'm for and that series because I
really liked the black hawks,
but I also,
I always like,
uh,
I say an underdog but I guess Nashville is his right as ranked higher.
But come on,
come on Black Hawks if want to this decade they know what to do.
All right.
So any predictions in the playoffs?
No,
not really.
I don't have any predictions because I barely watch this year cause I was really
busy.
Um,
although I watched pretty much most of the Bronx,
the tragedy of the Bruins.
Alright,
in reply to the podcast,
this guy says,
Bill,
here's a new way to get a flat stomach Italian doctor's plan.
The first human head transplant,
I swear to God this,
I can't say this is true.
It's on the Internet.
It's on medical,
what does it,
medical news today.
Dot Com.
Yeah,
30 year old Russian man volunteers for the first,
uh,
for world's first human head transplant.
And basically this guy has some,
a horrific disease,
uh,
where he's lost control of his body.
Um,
okay.
So he's like,
fuck it.
Why don't I get a new body?
Can you imagine if they pull this off?
Like I don't understand that.
How they're going to
chop the head off
and keep like,
think about that.
Okay.
As far as
my little know the anatomy,
every right now is everybody right now knowing I'm going waiting into these deep
waters right now.
She'd just be sitting there going,
Oh gee,
gee,
Gee,
go drag God love him.
He had me.
Um,
don't you have one intake hose?
The one outtake hose and like your brain's like a radiator,
right?
And the intake is like oxygenated blood.
And then the other shit coming out is that,
that's your blue blood right bound.
Now man,
amp,
amp and Ama now,
sorry,
Jack Black,
not Jack Black.
Jack White's,
sorry.
Um,
isn't that how it works?
So you basically,
you got to sever one of them.
I'd figure you'd sever the outtake first,
right?
To have,
you know,
and then what do you got to do?
You've got to hook that up to some sort of other machine that has a,
that's for the,
that's the outtake blood.
And then you got to do the other one for the end.
I don't know how to fuck are you going to do that?
It's going to be messy.
Is I want to know how to fuck they're gonna even try to do this.
You ever see somebody gets stabbed in a jug?
You'll just in the movies,
it's fucking insane if,
forget about an hockey,
you know when somebody comes in with a skate and catches a guy and it just
starts going out like a sprinkler and they even say they just nicked the
juggler,
right?
Anyways,
so they're going to do this.
Now if they actually pull this off,
this is some shit where you could potentially,
you're talking about like,
I dunno if you could live forever,
um,
because your brain's still fucking old,
right?
That becomes the problem.
But if your body is,
is,
is uh,
is messed up,
well,
wait a minute,
I'm not,
other than the obvious fucking question should be is who's the guy going to give
up his body
playing fucking musical chairs with the rest of your fucking torso there?
Let me read this here a little bit.
Ah,
this guy says I can hardly control my body.
Now he said,
I need help every day,
every minute.
I am now 30 years old,
although people rarely live to be more than 20 with this disease.
So this guy's crushing it.
All right?
Don't donor body will be attached to recipients head through spinal cord fusion.
What
doctor,
I can't even say the name of the doctor told CNN he received an array of emails
and letters from people asking to be considered for the procedure,
many of which have been from transgender individuals seeking a new body.
Jesus Christ.
Just when you thought like having your Dick remove was like the most like x
games thing you can do as far as like an operation.
These,
these guys are saying fuck it.
Cut My head off and put it on the opposite sex.
His body.
Jesus Christ.
I me Dang it.
This is like,
this is like Nazi doctor Shit.
This is fucking insane.
How the hell are you going to do that?
I can't wrap my head around it.
Um,
however the surgeon says the first people undergo the procedure will be those
with muscular wasting condition.
Like this uh,
spirit spirit don't have the procedure which is estimated to take a hundred
surgeons.
Gotcha.
100 surgeons around 36 hours to complete.
How the fuck are they going to all be around the table?
What are they going to,
I guess cause it's got to be 24,
seven do this is going to be like line changes in hockey except was surgeons,
the surgeons coming over the fucking boards except they were sleeping.
Come on,
you're up.
You're up.
Oh boy.
What,
where are we at?
Uh,
let's see.
The procedure which is going to take an estimated 100 surgeons around 36 hours
to complete will involve spinal cord fusion.
Scf for those in the business,
the head from a donor body will be removed using an ultra sharp blade in order
to live yet limit the amount of damage.
Right.
Damage to the spinal cord.
It's just,
I don't even think about that.
You're severing a spinal cord
now wait a minute.
If they can do that,
then they just cure paralysis.
How can you cut the fucking court on one guy and then stick it on another walk?
Cause you already have all the stuff.
Was that too technical?
Few guys.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
This is like on fast and loud.
When they took a fucking 2015 scad cat and they,
they,
they took the guts out of that and put it in the 71 except way harder.
Oh Geez.
Let's continue.
The spinal cord of the donor will be of the donor body will then be fused with
the spinal cord of the recipients head.
Oh,
so they'd just taken the spinal cord.
I thought they were taking the whole body chemicals called Perry.
I don't even try.
I called officer can be used to encourage spinal cord fusion according to Doctor
[inaudible],
the muscles and blood supply will then be sutured.
Oh,
so you mean when like he essentially bleeds out.
You're then going to suture to,
what
do please.
If they televise this,
I will watch all 36 hours.
Okay.
I will watch all 36 hours of how in the fuck you're going to cut somebody's head
off
at adds.
Unbelievable.
Okay.
The recipient will,
will be kept in a coma for around three to four weeks.
Said doctor [inaudible] during which time the spinal cord will be subject to
electrical stimulation via implanted electrodes in order to put,
this can't be,
let me get this straight.
They can't cure cancer,
but this guy's this,
this can't be real.
The surgeon estimates that with the help of physical therapy,
the patient would be able to walk within one year.
The fucking dude with the disease says he is worried undergo there was asked if
he was worried.
Am I afraid?
Yes,
of course I am.
But it is not it,
but it is not just very scary but also very interesting.
I mean,
I would watch it.
I don't think I would do it.
Okay.
Now wait a minute.
If they actually are able to do this then that those cryogenics people are
right.
And next thing you know,
Ted Williams,
unknown unknown lists.
Ted Williams could be walking around.
All right.
There you go.
There he did.
You did you laugh hard enough at me for sounding that fucking stupid.
All right,
Bill,
how about a rant about people complaining about Brady's first pitch?
You know what?
I didn't see it.
I would guess the reason why the pitch didn't make it to home plate was because
of those four rings on his throwing finger.
Huh?
What are you people just going to admit?
He's better looking than you.
He has more championships than you.
He's taller than you and he has a better look and wife than you.
It's fucking over game set.
Match straight sets.
Okay.
You didn't return one ball.
He aced you every fucking game you lost.
Six love six love six.
Love
the ball was always in chalk was always flying up when he was serving.
Um,
what do you think about it?
I don't give a shit.
He's a quarterback.
He's not supposed to be able to throw a baseball.
Okay.
He throws a man size ball,
not that little fucking beanbag that those guys are throwing.
All right.
Um,
you guys are really going with some heavy shit here.
Fill this will,
uh,
this will get your brain cord twisting thoughts,
earth's magnetic reversal.
Uh,
yeah,
this,
you know what,
I'll post this video.
This is a video about how the,
the north and South Poles are now moving,
which is really pissing me off as I'm learning about aviation and all this shit.
I'm finally figuring out the difference between true north and magnetic north
and all this type of shit.
And every,
evidently not only other polls going to shift.
So compass is what work.
The atmosphere is just not going to be able to,
we're just going to disappear.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't give a shit that the earth's magnetic poles are reversing.
Okay.
Or moving towards one another.
I could completely give a shit for the,
I wish that they weren't,
but,
um,
there's nothing I can do about it.
That's like when people sit there and go,
dude,
you live on top of a super volcano.
I think that is super fantastic.
And if it goes off,
I'm not even going to know what happened as opposed to you guys who will be
living in some,
I don't know what you'll,
you'll be,
you'll look at,
you'll watch the sun disappear for the last time in your life is what's going to
happen is you,
you're under that fucking
clouds of ash and everything dies.
I mean,
I don't want to be part of that.
You got it.
But you have to watch,
you gotta watch this youtube video and just the fucking,
the level of egg shit going on there.
If you're better man than me,
if
you can watch that whole video and not hate the person that did the,
the,
uh,
the voiceover,
you know,
not be so insecure that you fucking don't hate the person that did the voiceover
because the dude was annoying the shit out of me.
Um,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like doctors over here at blue,
that theory out of the water.
Oh,
did they guy who made the video and didn't do any fucking research?
I'm all right.
Sorry.
Hey Bill,
do a rant on Bait Click ads.
The ones that say he did this and you won't believe what was next.
Yeah,
I fell for that for about 40 times.
Uh,
first 40 times.
I don't,
I deliberately do not click on those anymore.
They're fucking annoying as shit.
And uh,
oh my God.
Trying to find like the be the top or those ones that go like the top worst nose
jobs ever.
And you're like,
all right,
let me look at these.
And then you get to the first photo and there's like no fucking way it seems to
get to the next one without clicking on a fucking ad for a Buick or something.
I can't believe advertisers are paying for that.
Like I can't remember anything I've ever seen.
And if I did,
I,
I wouldn't buy it because it was annoying the way I found out about it.
But you know,
it's funny,
there's this theory in advertising like,
you know,
you don't remember it,
but your subconscious remembers it.
Ooh,
right.
Such bullshit.
But you know what,
if it puts fucking fool loops on the table,
God bless him.
Yeah.
Um,
Bill,
please give us a take on today's fight for 15 protests.
People just microwave poisonous food.
Want $15 an hour.
I don't know what fight for 15 is.
Is that for $15 an hour?
I don't give a shit when people,
uh,
you know,
poor people want more money.
I don't,
that does not bother me as much as,
unless that lazy,
you know,
and they're not doing a good job,
microwave and the food and then they should just get fired,
you know?
But if you're actually busting your aspect,
I don't give a fuck that you want money.
You know,
I don't give a shit that they want Ronald to fucking undo the purse strings.
I bought all the rich content at the top.
This is why I'll never understand republicans is their hatred of the poor.
You know,
I'll never understand it.
I'm not saying I,
I actually like Democrats either.
I don't like Democrats as far as politicians go because they try to act like
they're the friends of people of the middleclass important than not.
It's like you the same fucking guy.
You sitting down eating the same God damn dinner,
five grand a fucking plate.
All right,
you're in bread with the same fucking people,
so go fuck yourself.
So there's more of an honesty with Republicans,
but I just don't understand why they hate the fucking poor.
Why they blame them.
Okay.
For everything.
It's just fucking around.
I mean you've got a small group of fucking concept.
The topic literally turned out food supply and poison and these idiots would
rather rant about personalities,
which is a fucking kills me God.
Damn apple causes will cause cancer.
I guarantee you in the future,
the ones that don't turn brown cause these guys are fucking with them cause this
sick and not making all the money on all the fucking apples.
I just,
I don't know,
I am such a fucking pessimists.
I actually think that it's great that the atmosphere is going to be sucked out
of the planet and we're all going to die.
I think it's a tremendous fucking thing.
It needs to happen,
right?
Don't you think?
Come on,
be honest,
haven't we?
We kind of played out.
I think human beings at this point.
Do you know that band that just keeps touring,
playing there?
Hit?
I think that that's where we're at right now.
You know what I mean?
We're like,
uh,
what was that?
That's that band.
Big country.
You know,
there's probably still somewhere right now singing in a big country.
[inaudible] stay with you.
I go to La,
that's actually a great song and I'm lead singer killed himself,
but you know,
you know,
you know the,
the breast of the band still going.
They're still playing that fucking song,
right?
You got some guy that just sounds like him,
but he's like Filipino.
Was that journey?
I have no idea.
Anyways,
but winding down here,
what else do we got here?
Oh God,
it's disgusting.
Picture of some hot chick laying next to a dead giraffe that you just shot.
Ricky Gervais' trasher and uh,
she tried to say that it was dying anyways in the villagers wanted her to kill
it.
That doesn't,
that just sound like a bunch of bullshit.
Like,
oh,
they wanted you to kill it.
They couldn't kill it themselves.
They only live out there and they've just been sitting there forever in the
middle of the Africa going,
Gee,
I wish some white lady would show up and kill a giraffe for us.
We're really hungry.
I don't believe in that.
I think she just likes killing big shit and then doing a stupid photo next to
it.
I don't understand people that go out and kill lions.
I think you're a fucking asshole if you do that.
Even if you shoot a bear and unless the bear is wandering into a the
neighborhood,
you know what I mean?
I don't understand how you can go out,
go ahead and go shoot a deer.
I don't give a fuck.
This is a zillion of them.
I guess if there's a lot of bear,
you've got to shoot them too.
But I mean,
I know there's not a lot of lions.
You got to shoot one and then stand on it and show it's fucking teeth.
I just don't,
I don't,
um,
I respect the skill of hunting as far as,
I feel like people should know how to do it,
but I that whole,
uh,
posing with the animal after you shot it,
like,
you know,
you guys just had a bare knuckle fight and you fucking knock that out.
I mean,
just the amount of shit you ever watched,
the hunting channel,
he's fucking assholes.
They got like a,
they got like a loft apartment up in a tree covered in the urine of the animal
and then they got this little fucking Kazoo.
It sounds just like a fucking turtle or whatever.
Right?
I mean,
how much more can the game be rigged just fucking sitting?
You've got all this fucking state of the yard.
Shit do.
We are the most evil animal on the planet and I know I'm part of it.
I know I'm a fucking part of it.
The shit that we do to animals is absolutely horrific.
Now I will always be a mediator.
So the way I justify my eval is I try to,
I just try to eat chickens.
I eat fucking cows.
Uh,
pigs.
Yeah.
And I don't give a fuck about pigs,
cows and chickens.
I feel bad for it because they'd never eat meat,
but a pig,
a pig would eat me.
I've watched enough movies,
Hollywood movies that are based on nothing but horseshit,
uh,
to know that that's actually a true thing.
That if,
you know,
if you killed me,
you could feed me.
Do a pig,
right?
Pigs need eight to go to the gym every day.
Um,
oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
I,
I just,
there's no need for that.
There's no need for it.
It's just something fucking annoying about laying there with a big stupid grin
on your face.
Although I will say she's Kinda hot.
She looks like a Pan Am stewardess to me way back in the day.
Coffee,
tea or me,
remember that shit.
You could actually,
you could actually fuck a waitress back in the day.
A mirror was a little kid seeing it go down.
And I'd be like,
Mommy,
what's going on there?
And she'd be like,
son,
uh,
he's in first class and you have to understand that they get extra,
extra perks.
And I said,
well,
next time can we fly first class?
And she just looked straight ahead and shook her head.
And that was the last time I talked to my mother.
Um,
all right,
what do we got here?
Woman fattened up by boyfriend to deter rivals.
Says yes to marriage proposal after two years of binge eating.
Oh my God,
that's not true.
Jealous Boyfriend.
Fatten up girlfriend to put off any love rivals.
I'm calling bullshit on this one.
If this was true,
wouldn't that be a bunch of fucking women's groups stomping around and
complaining and making up Horse Shit and then having to fucking apologize for
it.
You know what I mean?
That's the one thing about the woman's movement at this point.
They're literally,
they,
they've,
they've been bitching for so long.
I think they're getting dangerously close to just having to make up shit.
So this is,
this is seeming like this is part of it.
I chew.
Oh my God,
that's fucking hilarious.
Instead of saying,
I do,
they wrote,
I chew.
Oh,
it's Daily Mail.
Those clients who like to make up shit,
I don't believe a fucking word of this woman who was fattened up by jealous
boyfriend and deter love rivals says yes to marriage proposal.
After two years of binge eating,
Yantai weighed just over two,
just over seven stone.
Oh,
is that what she weighed?
What the fuck is with England?
Can you fucking get a God damn number in there?
When she began dating seven stone,
how many sticks did she wait?
Couple of fags.
Um,
by two years on and she was,
she has ballooned to almost double her weight.
You splashed out on meals every day in a plea.
What?
Oh,
you is?
The guy's name should say young daily meals.
The fucking worst.
You know what they type the way I read.
Um,
all right,
let's get off of this fucking thing.
Where are we?
Let's go back there.
Uh,
well,
you know,
she is a,
uh,
she is a human being and she has the ability to say a no thank you.
I'm full.
So that's on her and that's not blaming the victim there.
That's empowering the victim where you know,
you're the deal.
You have the ability to say,
listen,
I'm done with this shit.
I need to get on a treadmill.
Okay,
I don't want any more orange chicken.
All right now fuck off.
Then she's so fat.
You can't hear it cause it like a cheeks are so close to death.
Oh.
And he's like,
I'm sorry I can't understand you.
Is he sticking another fucking dumpling?
I swear to God.
I find if I dated it,
authentic Asian woman,
by authentic,
I mean from,
from,
from the motherland.
Okay.
And she could throw down with dumplings that we have to be over.
You think I got a big head now.
It'd be fucking over.
When I was in Hong Kong.
I might tell you something,
that dim sum I went to with some of the best fucking food I've ever had in my
life.
You know what I mean?
You ever had chicken and dumplings?
It's an insult to the way that the dumplings are made over in Asia.
It was incredible.
I would be,
well,
I guess that wouldn't be fat.
Nobody was really fat over there.
How do they do it?
Oh Dude,
go blue.
Um,
all right,
nick.
Daisy
says a German came in second to Bruce Jenner at the 76 Olympics.
How do you think he's handling Bruce's journey out?
Gives a fuck.
What are you saying?
Cause he,
he lost to a guy wants to be a woman or if he's actually like at enough,
he has issues with that.
I mean,
can you just reconcile it with that?
He was a man.
He was a man when he did it.
Right.
Does that means anything?
I don't fucking,
I don't even know.
You know,
that's one of those fucking questions.
Say you just,
you just,
this one of those things you can't joke about in a bar,
but if you actually put it on Twitter,
then it becomes,
it's like,
what are you saying?
Are you saying that people can't?
Huh?
Um,
all right.
The old men at the gym who use blow dryers to dry their junk.
What do I tell them?
Or they just blow in junk stuff into the locker room.
I don't know what to tell you.
I think I already addressed that one.
I want to do one more here and then I got to get the fuck outta here.
I gotta get on with my day and you guys can then listen to some classic clips
from the FM podcast that goes back to 2007 Ah,
why don't we come up with you with today.
All tongue tied Billy today.
Um,
hey old Billy slap shot.
How about a rant about the islanders moving to Brooklyn?
Yeah,
I don't understand why that has to happen.
I think what happened was there was,
they built that Barclays Center,
whatever the fuck it's called and then all of a sudden Nassau Coliseum started
looking like an old car and they wanted him to leave.
I think it stinks.
I think it's cool that the islanders are out there.
Everything that was cool about hockey's just going away,
like just the weird places that they had teams.
You know what I mean?
I just back in the day,
do you realize back in the day,
Boston,
Quebec,
Montreal,
buffalo in Hartford,
you could drive,
I mean,
whatever.
Montreal,
Quebec,
we're a little bit of a drive,
but they were all within like a fucking 45 minute flight of each other.
They were all bunched up right there,
right
monetary.
The Canadians,
the Nordiques,
the Bruins,
the way was in the sabers.
All right.
Those five teams,
that was the Adams Division and then right underneath them they had like
another,
like six or seven teams.
You had the islanders,
the Rangers,
the devils,
the fly and the capitals.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
another five fucking teams.
Then he had to go way out to western Pennsylvania for Pittsburgh.
He had basically yet 10 teams.
There were all like within an hour flight of each other,
hour and a half,
like it was insane.
It was like a major league baseball.
When it first came out.
We,
you had the red sox and Braves were in Boston.
You had three teams in New York.
He had two teams in Philly.
Actually you,
you,
you literally could have traveled by train back in the day just kills me that
they're just going to gradually move them to all the same fucking cities that
every other goddamn major sports team is in.
I,
I don't like it to be honest with you.
And I missed last night's game for some reason.
That one I didn't,
I couldn't find what that thing was televised so I missed the capital's
islanders game.
Uh,
both of those teams I really like.
And um,
you know,
I don't know.
That's a weird match up for me cause I liked Johnny Boychuk some room for him
but I also like Ovechkin so whatever.
We'll see.
We'll see how it pans out.
I'm all right.
That's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
I hope you enjoy some of these classic clips and a next time I talked to you
guys,
I'm going to be on the bus tour with Paul Versey and Jason Lawhead and hopefully
I'll be able to get those two clowns on the podcast.
We'll be able to update you along the ways we make our way through the deep
south and onto the Kentucky Derby.
All right,
you guys have a nice,
wonderful weekend.
I guess I should say.
Maybe it'd be nice at the ends of these
Katie,
go fuck yourself on Monday and then on Thursday.
[inaudible]
anyways,
um,
let's
read,
uh,
what the fuck was I going to read here?
Questions are already did this,
this is called broads over there.
Barrage over there.
I don't know what the hell it says.
Let's read this one.
Bill.
I had been a fan of yours sometime.
You just want to tell you that I think you're a great thank you.
Why don't I fucking delete those?
Um,
I think you're calm neve up.
All right.
Anyways,
the reason I am writing you is to tell you a funny story.
Uh,
my girl dating five plus years now and I live in Tucson,
Arizona and she's always bitching at me saying,
we never do anything anymore.
Well,
my job is very consuming of my time and I realized that she was correct.
So what do I do?
So what I do is I try to come up with something we could do together that would
be entertaining and unique,
something different that is not an average night out in Tucson se.
The guy's using his brain,
trying to surprise her.
Anyways,
I've been telling her about your comedy and showing her clips of you,
uh,
that I found on your myspace page for the past few months.
She really seemed to enjoy it and laughed hysterically.
So I planned this great evening for the 20th of November,
um,
which goes something like this,
head up to temp Eav,
have a nice dinner and head over to the Improv and watch your show.
Uh,
your eight o'clock show.
Um,
while I bought the tickets and thought I would surprise her with the whole
thing,
she loved the idea and she was very excited and I was supposed to pleased to see
her excited about the event.
Well,
we were telling our friends about it and she sort of says this,
well,
it's his evening and I'm just thought of tagging along.
Uh,
I got to admit that,
um,
I was a little upset at this point because I intended this whole thing to be a
gift from me to her,
which is funny because this is very similar to the story that you told on
October 19th on the October 19th podcasts when you took your girl in the
corvette up the PCH.
She just showed us shut.
Uh,
she just showed it sort of shut me down.
Um,
so my question to you is why is it never enough?
Uh,
what a great question.
Do you realize you just ask the question of properly every guy on this fucking
podcast,
um,
hold on.
I'm just going to pause here while the women roll their eyes and I,
God,
that's bullshit.
That's not true.
You know,
you got to use your imagination.
Women like surprises.
They just fucking
shut up.
Just shut up.
Would you just shut up and take off all those fucking layers?
It's not the 18 hundreds,
you know,
with your panties and your panty hose and you slip and you're fucking skirt.
All right.
What am I talking about?
I Dunno.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I lost my place.
It's my question to you is why is it never enough?
I can do everything she wants,
but she was still find a way to make me look like an asshole.
Making me a,
making it seem like I'm dragging her around and making,
do all that stuff that I want to do.
I guess that is why I relate to your comedy because it seems that she is only
happy when we do all the things that she wants to do.
Uh,
you don't,
I'm talking,
you know what I'm talking about with Brunch Street Fairs and the candle store.
Uh,
nevertheless,
we are going and really looking forward to seeing you in person.
Uh,
I hope to see you have to show selling some cds and DVDs.
All right.
Um,
why is it never enough?
I don't know.
I don't know why.
I don't know if it's an insecurity that they are,
they're always questioning whether you truly love them or not.
Um,
I have no idea.
I don't know why.
I mean,
I would think
that.
All right,
look,
look at me.
Okay.
I went,
I rented a corvette for the day,
core Vectren verbal and I drove my girl all around La.
We went up the fucking Pacific coast highway,
looked at the ocean,
we had lunch.
I took her out to this beautiful bar late at night.
I drove it through the Hollywood hills with the top down,
looking at the stars,
looking at the lights out over the city.
I thought it was a very romantic thing and then I got on the podcast and she was
just like,
yeah,
that was really just,
that was really your thing.
I just did that for you.
You know,
I just thought of sat there and a $70,000 automobile,
you know?
Okay.
Seeing views that people fly six hours to say and just,
you know,
just got a free lunch out of it and free fucking drinks and you ever watched the
prices right there.
You just spit on my own microphone and you ever,
a price is right.
You have watched the prices,
right?
Sure.
We all have.
Okay.
Getting a corvette,
I mean like,
and then going to that restaurant and driving up to PCH and looking at the
lights and going up to the fucking bar in the hotel with John Belushi.
Oh,
deed,
isn't it?
That sounds like one of the,
one of those showcases that you bid on.
Are you going to bid
pass
this thing here for the podcast bill?
This is under women and
diamonds.
Um,
so bill,
I'm at a party last night and I see a guy you haven't seen in a long time.
He's got his girl with them.
She's pretty hot,
but she's got this look on her face.
Uh,
we,
we were introduced earlier,
so I say,
so I say hey to her and uh,
and ask her what's wrong?
Turns out she's had a few,
a few drinks and is throwing around the,
I want to get married.
Shit.
Um,
I don't think my buddies having any of it or at the very least plans to go down
swinging.
Um,
so anyways,
nothing like a party to bring that shit up anyway.
So I figured this is the perfect opportunity to test out a new theory.
I have about diamonds.
I'm not really a theory,
but a great question that allows women to show their true colors.
Why do I do this?
Because I'm a smart ass jerk when to have a few whiskeys.
I like this guy.
This guy sounds like me.
Right?
Why would you actually try to get the girl on your side and well actually you
wouldn't hook up with your buddies girl,
but you know what I mean?
Why would you put out a good vibe when you can actually piss people off?
I totally relate to that.
Um,
anyways,
second half here.
Anyway,
from what I understand,
you can basically,
now,
I don't know if this is true or not,
but this guy's claiming from what I understand,
you can basically buy a real diamond created in a lab.
Um,
eventually they will be much cheaper than the ones they have to dig out of the
ground and they will also be flawless.
A fucking perfect diamond.
So I asked this girl,
I say,
if she,
if she would rather have a perfect,
flawless diamond created in a lab that costs a lot less or insist on a real dug
out of the ground diamond by some poor person in Africa,
nearly perfect,
but ultimately flawed more than it's an expensive one.
Um,
he,
he said you can pretty much guess her answer.
Once again,
women are fucking stupid about diamonds.
Uh,
all right.
My first question is can they really create one in a lab that's much cheaper and
if they,
if they can for the love of God,
shut the fuck up.
Guff
about it.
That should be some low like Guy Shit,
you know,
and,
and this is what,
this is what we would do like you,
this is,
this is the level that you organize it to our,
I just so they don't catch on,
you know,
because some guy who fucking stock shelves at seven 11 is able to buy the hope
fucking diamond,
the broads.
We'll be able to figure it out quickly.
So what we should do is organize this shit like the beginning of the warriors,
except nobody shoots Cyrus,
okay?
We organize this shit and this is what we say.
You come in with your w two for the fucking year,
all right?
We see what you make and then we give you an unbelievable fucking diamond from
making that amount of money,
whatever we rather than,
what's it supposed to cost?
Six weeks' pay.
We give you one that costs like 10 weeks,
you know,
put some fake beads of sweat on your fucking brow when you give it to her and
the whole thing's going to look legit and me while we take that money to go buy
a new flat screen.
All right?
And that's when you make the fucking move.
Or after you give it the diamond.
Okay?
Say I bought that diamond for you.
Now I want to buy something from me.
Actually,
why don't you help me out on this?
Just throw me a hundred,
200 bucks in this thing.
You go out,
you get a big fucking flat screen TV.
You get the fucking dish just in time for NFL football.
You know,
and I'm sure they offer a college football fucking package and then you just
spend the rest of the football season Saturday and Sunday and total fucking
bliss.
And anytime she gives you shit just be like,
I'm sorry honey,
I couldn't hear you over the glare of the fucking diamond I put on your God damn
finger.
That's what,
well that's what should have happened.
If I had half a brain,
I want to read that part over the Goddamn a podcast.
But um,
I actually get that on some level.
Why she would want the other one.
I don't get it because I don't want to think about some poor kid digging that
out of the ground.
That's the part where it goes off the rails.
But they want,
you know,
they want something of value,
and they,
they,
I dunno if they want to show that they married a provider.
I get it on some level.
They want to make their friends jealous.
Like,
um,
I think their obsession with diamonds,
you know,
generally speaking is as dumb is our obsession with sports.
Because when you really think about it,
our obsession with sports is really fucking stupid.
You know,
sitting on your couch like a Goddamn cheerleader wearing the jersey of your
favorite player.
I mean,
not everybody does that,
but they're,
you know,
fantasy football.
Well,
I mean,
fantasy football to me is the male version of sex and the city of women watching
sex in the city.
For you to sit around and play fantasy football and get together with your
friends and have a fucking draft,
I mean,
you might as well do it in a Goddamn tree fort.
It's really one of the gayest fucking things you could possibly do.
And of course I am saying this,
having never tried it and I know God damn well fight tried it.
I'd be like,
this is fucking awesome,
you know,
pass the dip or whatever you fucking guys do.
Um,
but anyways,
I dunno,
I just,
I,
you know,
look,
this is,
if I've learned anything in life,
women are crazy and guys are fucking idiots.
And,
uh,
it's not straight across the board,
but generally speaking,
yeah,
they're fucking nuts.
They're out of their minds and we're more on,
I mean,
would you,
if you go on youtube and you just look up those fail videos,
most of them are guys trying to do something and they fucking get hit in the
balls,
land on the back of their head,
wreck their car.
How many women are driving down the street on a fucking motorcycle going 90
miles an hour trying to stand up on the seat.
Doing the karate kid pose is they point at the fucking camera and then fucking
skin get skin their fucking asses.
I mean,
how many,
you know what I mean?
How many guys,
how many fucking women are,
are,
are fucking whatever that move that Asian dude does or whatever,
where he fucking somehow gets his car to be doing donuts and he actually gets
out of the car and is holding onto the steering wheel and it's still spinning
around.
Somehow he's got the gas pedal
pushed all the way down.
Basically in the end he gets run over by his own fucking car.
I mean,
we're idiots.
All right.
Women on the other hand going to movies and start crying like they actually know
the people on straight
get all excited about shiny shit.
And,
uh,
I gotta be honest.
I don't even know what the fuck they get excited about.
I,
I have such a difficult time listening to them.
Alex,
such a great chauvinist Dick thing to say as I fucking took a slug.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].